une histoire de gangster en tournage
actuellement tournage d'un film en
région parisienne en forêt
d'hermenonville le tournage de la rumba
le réalisateur c'est Roger an avec comme
acteur nilrup la participation lin
Ventura et Michel picoli Nicole
cornanglois et didan sont allés voir ce
tournage une partie de ce tournage de
[Musique]
laarumba
spectacle insolite sur une calme route
de forêt en plein été illusion du cinéma
qui reconstitue des faits et une époque
sous l'œil attentif et gognard de Roger
annin réalisateur et acteur de la
RBA pas ptin
bon
utilisation habile de l'hémoglobine pour
transformer des vivants en victimes il
s'agit de de des frères roséie que j'ai
rebaptisé tosell et c'est la séquence
que vous voyez là c'est leur assassinat
par les par les hommes de la cagoule
enfin le film c'est autre chose qu'
qu'un fait divers politique c'est
surtout une réflexion sur la dualité
entre la frivolité d'une époque c'est 38
39 avant la guerre avec toutes les
danses de l'époque le black bot B le
Boston Jaz New Orleans qui arriv et en
même temps cette guerre qui est arrivé
que les gens pas pas vu à les
protagonistes mich
Picol Corine t attend comme il arrive
souvent au cinéma il faut suivre les
conseils du
réalisateur se faire maquiller
patiemment se concentrer avant les
scènes après un règlement de compte
sanglant je vais aussi euh aussi
détruire mon patron et donc assassiner
Michel
picoli pour se préparer à cette fin
tragique Michel picoli doit subir toute
une installation très
minutieuse bien parce que quand je
mouris vraiment comme ça j'y croirais
pas je penserais que c'est du
cinéma pens à la scène que vous allez
tourner ou oh pas du tout je suis en
train de le regarder faire et ça m'amuse
bien ça m'amusera toujours
n tricherie au cinéma c'est ce qui plus
beau vous allez mourir tout à l'heure
dans la scène pour quelle raison vous
allez mour parce
que parce que je joue un vain comme dis
les Américains mais j'ai trouvé plus vil
que
moi et c'est tout un art de bien mourir
au
cinéma